maybe getting a sense of numbers
how many stars are there in um
maybe i don't know what the radius
that's
reasonable to think about i don't know
if the observable universe
is like way too big to think about but
in terms of when we think about how many
habitable planets there are
what are the numbers we're working with
in your sense
what are the scale honestly the numbers
are probably like billions of trillions
of stars yeah you know in the uk i think
i don't know if we do that here but they
will call a billion trillion
where you put like 1 billion followed by
a trillion
yeah it's kind of weird but here i don't
even know how to say the number 10 to
the 20. like if you know what that is
that's one followed by 20 zeros that's a
big number
and we don't have a name for that number
there's so many
per star i think we kind of mentioned
this is there a good sense there's
probably argument about this but
per star how many planets
are there is is there we don't have that
number yet per se you know we're not
really there but
some people think that there's many
planets per star there's this analogy of
filling the coffee cup like you know you
don't usually just pour one drop you
fill it and that planetary systems
we see stars being born that have a disk
of gas and dust
and that ultimately forms planets so the
idea this kind of concept is that
planets
so many planets form too many and
eventually some get kicked out and
you're left with like a full planetary
system a dynamically full system and so
there have to be a lot because so many
form
and a bunch survive that i mean that
that makes perfect intuitive sense right
like why wouldn't that happen
right well there's other thoughts too
though these big planets that are really
close to the star
we think they formed far away from the
star where there's enough material to
form
and they migrated inwards and some of
these planets migrating inwards due to
interaction with other planets or with
the disk itself they may have cleared it
out
like kicked other planets out of the
system so there's a lot of ideas
floating around
we're not entirely sure and what about
earth-like planets is that that's
another level of uncertainty that it's a
level of uncertainty if we think of an
earth-like planet
being an earth around a sun in the same
orbit
an earth-like planet being an
earth-sized planet in an earth-like
orbit about a sun-like star
we're not there yet you know we're not
able to detect enough of those to
to give you a hard number some people
have extrapolated
and they will say as many as one in five
stars like our sun
could be hosting a true earth-like
planet
you